معنى الالم من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميد
الياس حنا يعني واضح بان
حرب المسيرات المتبادله الان يتصدر هذا
المشهد اليوم هناك حديث عن غواصه تعمل
بالوقود النووي تحمل صواريخ فرط صوتيه بعد
استراتيجيه اوكرانيه تضرب طرق الامداد
الروسيه ما الذي يجري في هذه
الاستراتيجيات
ايمان موضوع موضوع الغواصه يعني الغواصات
الروسيه هي من الاهم في العالم والاقوى
وتعتبر نقطه القوه لدى البحريه الروسيه
اليوم التزويد بزيركون الفرد صوتي تسع
مرات سرعه الصوت الف كيلو متر ما يقارب
400 كم الراس الحربي للاهداف المضاده
البحريه يعني ضد الحاملات الطائرات وقد
يكون ضمن الاهداف البريه هذا الامر موجه
اكثر الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
موجهه اكثر الى الغرب موجه اكثر الى
النيتو لانه استعماله في الداخل الاوكراني
يعني يصبح الكثير من الاسلحه والكثير من
الصواريخ
الاسكندر وما شابه كلها تستعمل ضمن
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هذا امر زاد بعد
استراتيجي اكثر منه على البعد العملاني
على الساحه الاوكرانيه هي رساله للغرب
ولكن هذا لا يمنع انها قد العمل هذا
السلاح هذا صاروخ فرد صوتي تذكرنا كنجال
على انه فرض صوتي يبقى موضوع التجربه
ايمان يعني ما هي الرساله الموجهه ما هو
فحوى هذه الرساله اذا كانت موجهه الى
الولايات المتحده والغرب
العميد هناك اكثر من ست او سبع قواعد
عسكريه بحريه مهمه منها في الشرق الاقصى
في الاطلسي يتم حاليا نقل بعض هذا العتاد
وبعض هذه الغواصات الى تلك المنطقه وكانه
يتم تحضير لمرحله معينه تعاون رؤوس الصيني
ما في مكان ما في في الشرق الاقصى وايضا
من التجارب هذا الامر يدل او رساله للغرب
وللولايات المتحده الامريكيه على ان
الهيمنه الهيمنه البحريه للبحريه
الامريكيه التي تملك ما يقارب 10 الى 11
حامل الطائرات هي ليس امرا مؤكدا هناك من
يتحدى وهناك من يقول انا موجود ايضا في
القوه البحريه يعني لا تتحدث عن تعاون
روسي صيني اليوم الولايات المتحده تعلن عن
حزمه جديده من المساعدات الى اوكرانيا هل
فهمت برايك الولايات المتحده تلك الرساله
يعني وفحواها
التي ترسل بها روسيا الان
وسارعت الى يعني امداد اوكرانيا بتلك
المساعدات الاضافيه
الموضوع زيركون والغواصات موضوع اكبر من
الساحه الاوكرانيه ولكن اليوم هذا استمرار
المساعدات الامريكيه هذا استمرار لمتطلبات
الامر الميداني العملاني على الارض من هنا
نوعيه الاسلحه ذخيره لنزع الالغام ذخيره
مضاده للدبابات صواريخ باتريوت وما شابه
هذا الامر هو من متطلبات الحرب التي تجري
لهم خلال الهجوم الاوكراني ايمان الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث اليوم او يرد على من
اتهم استراتيجيه او هجومه المضاد
بالفشل برايك كيف هو التقييم لهذا الهجوم
المضاد او هذه الاستراتيجيه المضاده
الاوكرانيه الان ولماذا تراجع الحديث عنها
في الاونه الاخيره
اليوم الهجوم متعثل الى حد ما وتقول
القياده الاوكرانيه العسكريه انه على
شاكله الماراثون وليس على سباق المئه متر
السريع جدا الموضوع بعيد يتطلب وقت هناك
ثلاثه محاور اساسيه تهاجم فيها اوكرانيا
في الوسط في اوريكيف
وفي مخموض وهي تدافع حاليا في كوبيانس
يعني هذا الامر مهم جدا من هنا اتت هذه
المساعدات العسكريه نتحدث عن جبهه طولها
900 كم
مجهزه ومحضره مسبقا لهداء لدفاع مرن بعمق
30 كيلومتر الكثير الاكثر نشرا للالغام في
العالم ايمان من هنا هذه الصعوبه
الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه اليوم هي ضرب
الخلفيه واللوجستيه الروسيه اشكرك العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
كنت معنا من بيروت